az a az a szépebbe hogy eljön az a pont
amikor a felületes válaszok nem
elegendőek tehát akkor muszáj a
legmélyebb kérdést feltenni és akkor
akkor ha tehát nekem mindig problémám
volt azzal a fajta motivációs
eszközökkel hogy a tükörbe belenézel és
elmondod azt hogy szép vagy vagy a
tükörbe belenézel és azt mondod hogy ma
sikeres leszek és akkor bevonzom
magamnak a pozitív dolgokat nem
mintogyha nem hinnék a szavaknak a
teremtőerejében hanem az hogy ez
felületes annyira felületes annyira
jelentéktelen ez amikor amikor
céltalanul bolyongsz az életbe és nem
kapod az utadat akkor hiába mondod
ezeket